[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants alors tout le monde
joue à cache cache ce soir vous voulez
pas trop nous faisons une gigantesque
partie de cache-cache fonds propres et
personne ne me trouvera pour les châles
et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop
si vous ne faites pas de bruit il nous
trouvera pas chichi et voilà
bourgou
ils ont déjà caché les coca
ou peuvent-ils bien être
les rideaux
derrière les rideaux
personne de la réflexion de l'ours
assieds toi sur ce coffre et réfléchi
ils ont sûrement une bonne cachette
oh ça bouge à dessous des connards pape
rhône elle veut les voir il ya des
souris dans votre coffre à jouets ou la
halle ont du courage nounours même si
c'est une souris elle ne te manges
rapport
je les ai trouvés
si nicolas n'avait pas tout le temps
bouger ac oui mais je serai plus jamais
des neiges était grosse à présent c'est
à moi de me cacher allons tous les trois
la salle de bains et ne trichez pas
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
vos propos
nicolas pour toi c'est pas votre riche
et
ces garçons qui regarde par le trou de
la serrure et rend pas preneur j'y vois
rien oh là là où
la cuisine gourmands comme il est
il n'est pas là il est pas là
nous
excuser moi y'a quelqu'un dans z maison
je suis une étudiante allemande jeu
forte et jodo la fin nicolas limbach
distincts
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous voulez je chantais
judo pour les idiots
il faut trouver j'ai rien compris à ce
que raconte cette bonne femme
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire elles ont dit
tous les trois des jo pour les étudiants
là vous avez des rays n'ont rien à
manger petits journaux vais
vous pouvez partir bon groupe je
t'aime mon pote la
magie du color entre
vous et bien d'autres
je vais faire la même blague aux
marchands ne saurait
nous nous couchons l'inquiète pas je me
chauffe ce que je vais m'amuser
mademoiselle
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez moi mes yeux vous n'avez rien
contre les étudiants non j'aime beaucoup
les étudiants mademoiselle alors vous
mâche terreau est bien un journal mais
bien sur madmoizelle j'achète tous vos
journaux
bravo north temps déguisement était très
réussi bonne nuit des enfants beaux de
nuit je me tue qui seraient encore fait
pour
oh
[Musique]